momento de conocer Cuáles son las
principales noticias en materia
económica en Francia en español y por
eso nos acompaña Juan Pablo luco muy
buenas noches Juan buenas noches feliz
viernes Santiago feliz viernes para vos
también y para toda la audiencia que nos
acompaña en estos momentos bueno
comenzamos por la región concretamente
en Argentina vamos a hablar de la huelga
de trabajadores de transporte público
verdad Así es ya lo adelantábamos en el
noticiero una huelga que inició en la
mañana de este viernes y que culminó
sobre las 5:30 de la tarde hora local
pero que dejó a cientos de argentinos
varados en su rutina habitual para ir al
trabajo esto Pues en la región
Metropolitana de Buenos Aires y seis
provincias de ese país quienes lideraron
el paro piden Un aumento salarial y
alegan que las empresas no han cumplido
con el pago que pues de dicho aumento
que ya se acordó en el pasado
escucharemos a continuación las palabras
del ministro de economía argentino
Sergio massa y a algunos ciudadanos que
se vieron afectados por la huelga
los empresarios argentinos que arriesgan
que apuestan
pero a los que son parásitos del estado
y pretenden extorsionar les decimos no
les tenemos miedo los vamos a enfrentar
para defender el derecho de la gente a
viajar para ir a trabajar es muy
complicado para todos porque o se tiene
que pagar Uber y sale carísimo porque la
demanda está horrible Vengo desde
burzaco tengo que llegar a trabajar
nadie se hace responsable de que yo
pueda llegar a trabajar Yo lo único que
te pediría es que se devuelvan todo lo
que se robaron y seguro vamos no van a
meter el soldados bueno Juan en Beijing
avanzan las negociaciones entre las dos
principales economías del mundo Así es
avanzan las reuniones hoy y la
secretaria del tesoro de Estados Unidos
Janette criticó de forma directa las
recientes acciones de China contra las
empresas estadounidenses y los controles
de exportación de minerales recordemos
que Beijing acaba de imponer
restricciones a las exportaciones de
germanio y galio lo hemos estado
revisando durante esta semana utiliza
para la industria de alta tecnología lo
que se ve como un contragolpe a una
larga disputa comercial ella también
dejó bastante Claro que Washington y sus
aliados occidentales responderán
devolviendo El golpe a lo que ella llamó
como entre comillas prácticas económicas
desleales de China y esto lo dijo pues
que lo iba a pasar si era necesario
escuchemos
buscamos una sana competencia económica
que no sea donde el ganador se lo lleve
todo sino con un conjunto justo de
reglas que beneficien a ambos países
Estados Unidos en determinadas
circunstancias deberá emprender acciones
específicas para proteger su seguridad
nacional y es posible que no estemos de
acuerdo en estos casos pero no debemos
permitir que ningún desacuerdo conduzca
a malentendidos que empeoren
innecesariamente nuestra relación
económica y financiera bilateral
Santiago y es que hace pocos minutos se
conoció que el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden dijo a su homólogo
chino que tuviera cuidado con lo que
hacía ya que Beijing depende de las
inversiones occidentales esto lo dijo en
una entrevista con CNN dijo que esto no
era una amenaza sino una observación
algo que pone aún más tensas las
relaciones de estos dos gigantes de los
que previamente el Primer Ministro chino
comparó con el clima de su país
escuchemos
[Música]
usted llegó a nuestro aeropuerto y se
bajó del avión apareció un arcoíris en
el cielo es un fenómeno natural por
supuesto y es algo que vemos a menudo
pero creo que también debería aplicarse
a la relación entre China y Estados
Unidos creo que las relaciones entre
China y Estados Unidos son más que
viento y lluvia seguramente veremos más
arco iris bueno Juan y esto se encuentra
seguramente afectaron los mercados
mundiales no vamos a hablar ahora por
eso de los indicadores Así es vamos a
hablar de Asia Estados Unidos y nuestra
región empezamos con Asia porque las
bolsas en ese lugar cerraron en su
mayoría en números rojos el mayor
perdedor fue el principal indicador de
Tokio Japón quien acumuló una caída del
1,17% este viernes Hong Kong y Shanghai
siguieron la senda bajista pese al
optimismo de los líderes de Estados
Unidos y China los indicadores en Wall
Street también cerraron en rojo el
informe de empleo de este viernes
También movió los mercados cuando se
mostró que los empleadores
estadounidenses agregaron 209 mil
empleos el mes pasado una desde la
contratación de
306.000 en mayo sin embargo este
escenario de pérdidas no se trasladó
hasta América Latina O al menos no
afectó los principales indicadores de
Brasil y Argentina pues ambos cerraron
con considerables ganancias para un
viernes de jornada este cierre Juan
bueno precisamente vamos a revisar datos
de inflación de dos gigantes de la
región de América Latina hablamos de
México y de chile empezamos con el país
norteamericano porque ahí la inflación
general se desaceleró en junio por
quinto mes consecutivo ubicándose en
5,06% interanual esto supone además su
nivel más bajo desde marzo de 2021
cuando México vivía el periodo post
pandemia gran parte de este resultado
fue por la estricta política monetaria
del Banco Central pero este dato llegó
en armonía con el freno del ciclo
alcista de la tasa de interés de ese
país Algo similar como está sucediendo
en Estados Unidos que pues se rumora que
viene como este este momento de freno
ahora pasamos al país sudamericano de
Chile allí en junio la inflación
interanual se ubicó en 7,6% desde el
8,7% que registró en mayo con este dato
ya se empieza a hablar en el mercado
chileno de una posible un posible
escenario de recorte de tasas de interés
en las próximas semanas ya veremos que
suceda en estos países
Muchísimas gracias por otra completísima
Crónica en materia económica bueno se
viene un fin de semana pero nos volvemos
a ver pronto nos vemos el lunes con
mucha más información